foreign
welcome to this talk on from The Matrix
to the metaverse I'm David Chalmers and
I'm looking forward to exploring with
you some philosophical issues about
Virtual Worlds including the Matrix and
the metaverse two famous examples from
science fiction and quite a few others
besides
so the themes I'll be talking about
today
um I explored some length in a book I
just published a couple of weeks ago now
called realityplus
Virtual Worlds and the problems of
philosophy uh there's the US edition
with the butterfly and the uh the UK
Edition with clouds if you look closely
you can spot some hints of pixelation
maybe a hints of virtuality in uh in
reality today I'm just going to you know
go fairly quickly a quick romp through a
few key themes
um of the book if you're interested uh
you can explore them at much greater
length
um in this uh in this book the basic
idea here is a philosophical
inquiry into Virtual Worlds and virtual
realities I think they really raise
huge numbers of philosophical questions
and they actually shed light on many
traditional issues in philosophy as well
so my purposes I like to you know Define
terms when I can so one key term is a
virtual world
by a virtual world I mean an interactive
computer generated world
so here's an example uh the world of
of Our World of Warcraft a massive
multiplayer online video game where many
people go and hang out in this
computer-generated space which they can
interact with they can interact with
other people they can interact with the
world that's a video game virtual world
but Virtual Worlds don't need to be
video games here's the world of Second
Life which you know peaked around 2007
but still going still fairly big today
people use this for all kinds of social
purposes work play employment Community
Building relationships
um it's a really good so it's a
canonical Virtual Worlds but these two
virtual worlds are not yet virtual
reality
virtual reality requires a third
condition virtual reality is an
immersive interactive computer-generated
World here are the key extra condition
to be virtual reality is immersiveness
virtual reality or VR you experience
from the inside
three-dimensionally you're immersed in a
world that's all around you
um so World of Warcraft and second life
and not standardly experienced this way
but um there are many worlds now one can
experience through say a virtual reality
headset here's the Oculus Quest 2. I
have my own Oculus Quest 2. you just put
it on
and suddenly well there's a uh
three-dimensional world all around you
that you can experience and interact
with play games here's um
here's a The Game beat saver speed saver
where you could slash some cubes with
your lightsabers and time for the music
they're also social Virtual Worlds that
you can experience through VR as well
but for full scale
Virtual Worlds my two paradigms are the
Matrix and the metaverse both from
science fiction The Matrix is a paradigm
of the idea the whole universe might be
a simulation that we could end up to be
in a simulation ourselves
the murder of Earth is a paradigm of the
idea of virtual world technology that we
develop and then use and then enter
um a virtual world it comes from Neil
Stevenson's novel snow crash where uh
the metaverse was a place where people
increasingly spent time so this stands
for coming virtual reality technology
and I think all this requires
philosophical analysis both for
philosophical purposes and for practical
purposes
now I have a key unifying thesis
which is virtual reality is genuine
reality
and that has a number of sub Theses I
mean people very frequently
say that virtual reality is some kind of
fake or fictional reality it's a second
class reality it's an illusion that's
the thesis I want to reject I want to
say virtual reality is different from
physical reality but in many respects on
a power weather this breaks down into at
least three sub Theses first it's
possible that physical reality is
already virtual reality that is it's
possible that we are in virtual reality
already I don't say that we are in such
a virtual reality I don't even say
necessarily that it's more likely than
not but I think it
we might be and it's not something we
can rule out
second
I think virtual reality is not an
illusion or a fiction the objects we
interact with in VR are real objects
there are digital objects to be sure but
they're no less real for all that
needn't be an illusion or a fiction
third we can lead a meaningful life in
virtual reality
um it needn't be escapism it didn't even
be meaningless in principle many of the
sources of meaning of life in a physical
reality could also be present in virtual
reality so we'll try and defend those
three Theses fairly quickly
in what follows and I'll do this with
reference to these two you know these
two big temples Temple ideas of virtual
worlds I'll start with the Matrix which
illustrates the idea that we could be
living in a computer simulation
and then I'll switch to the metaverse
which illustrates the role of coming
virtual reality technology that will
that will use and increasingly spend our
spend our time in I think some of the
morals you get from The Matrix will then
generalize to apply to the metaverse
hence from The Matrix to the metaverse
but I'll start with the Matrix and with
the idea that we are in
a computer simulation sometimes called
the simulation hypothesis
the simulation hypothesis says we are in
a lifelong computer simulation so like
Neo at the beginning of the Matrix is in
a lifelong computer simulation
um by the time we get to Matrix
resurrections we've discovered okay
there's a stimulation there's a world
out there there's a there's a new video
game based on it there are modals there
are potentially simulations Within
simulations
but still many characters in the uh in
The Matrix at various points turn out to
be in this giant lifelong computer
simulation namely The Matrix they're
inside they're inhabiting a simulated
world this is great for a philosopher
because it's highly reminiscent of a
famous challenge issued by Rene
Descartes back in the 1640s in his
meditations on first philosophy
sometimes viewed as a founding work of
modern philosophy Descartes was
interested in the question how what can
we know how can we know it he asked the
question how do you know
anything about external reality how do
you know you're not dreaming right now
how do you know
[Music]
um that your senses aren't fooling you
or most famously how do you know an evil
demon isn't deceiving You by producing
Sensations as of an external world when
none of this is real these days we ask
that we ask that question by raising
questions like how do you know you're
not in a simulation here okay here I've
got a
a wonderful illustration of the evil
demon doing its work by actually
programming a simulation it's like this
is a high-tech evil demon feed signals
to a brain floating in a vet the brain
experiences the world
uh out there but started out does any of
that real and the Brain reassures itself
okay I know that at the very least least
I know that I am here thinking therefore
I exist I think therefore I am so the
brain is certain of its own existence
better
it has doubts about the external World
maybe I'm in uh maybe the evil demon is
fooling me by the way all these
illustrations are
um my wonderful illustrator illustrator
Tim peacock who did 57 illustrations uh
for this book reality plus and just did
an amazing job of bringing these
philosophical and science fiction
scenarios to life
so these days we pose Descartes question
by asking how do you know you're not in
a simulation
and it's very hard to see how you could
ever know for sure that you're not you
might think you could have some
conclusive evidence that you're not in a
simulation I don't know maybe the
behavior of your cat or your best friend
or something in nature somehow proves
we're not in a simulation
but it sure looks like in principle any
evidence could be simulated there could
be simulations of your cat or if your
best friend or about or of nature which
would in principle be indistinguishable
from physical reality maybe we'll be
there in a few years we'll actually
develop simulations like that to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas